وجد جاد الطبيب المختص في طب النساء
والتوليد مستقبله المهني في فرنسا منذ
وصوله اليها لاكمال دراسته فقرر البقاء
كحال الكثير من الكفاءات الطبيه من اصول
المغاربيه التي تستقطبها فرنسا بشكل دائم
ونرجع لتونس هذا الهدف الاساسي بعدين عشت
هون يعني سنه
يعني عملته وشفت الفرق الواسع الكبير
ونحكي على مجال الطب يعني ظروف العمل
المشهيه ذاتها ظروف حتى العلميه بتشتور من
حالك مش هي ذاتها يعني هون الظروف احسن
المشكله مش في فرنسا ولا في السياسه فرنسا
ولا في المشكل في البلد اللي انت فيه يعني
اذا كان انت بلدك موفر لكل الظروف ولكن
اذا بلدك موفر لك ظروف العمل وظروف العلم
وظروف التطور ابدا مش راح تفكر تطلع
وبينما تسعى الحكومه الفرنسيه الى تعزيز
قطاعها الصحي من خلال تسهيل قدوم الاطباء
جانب عبر منحهم بطاقه اقامه خاصه بهم وذلك
عبر سن مشروع قانون الهجره الجديد تزداد
مخاوف الدول المغاربيه وافريقيا
الفرانكفونيه التي تزود المستشفيات
الفرنسيه عاده بالعاملين في القطاع الصحي
من عمليه افراغ مؤسساتها الطبيه من
الاطباء
منذ سنوات اصبح النظام الصحي الفرنسي في
حاله توتر وبات الوصول الى الرعايه الصحيه
يتدهور تدريجيا بسبب عدم وجود عدد كافي من
العاملين نفيق هناك ضروره للزياده عدد
قبول الاطباء
فرنسا ليست البلد الوحيد الذي يستقطب
الكفاءات العلميه من تلك الدول اذ تشمل
هذه الظاهره بقيه الدول الغربيه الا ان
هذا المشروع قد يسبب هجره جماعيه لاطباء
الدول المغاربيه من سيؤدي الى تقليص فرص
سكانها في الحصول على العلاج
ضد الحكومه
الفرنسيه قانون الهجره الجديد قد تعود
بالفائده على فرنسا لحل ازمه نقص الاطباء
لكنها قد تسبب ذات الازمه في البلدان الام
خاصه في المناطق التي تعاني فقرا في اليد
العامله بالقطاع الصحي زينه عادي العربيه
باريس